her current whereabouts are unknown in
the months leading up to galen maxwell's
2020 indictment nobody seemed to know
where she was we never stay in one place
for any
length of time security advisor matt
hellyer helped maxwell keep a low
profile hellyer and maxwell's family
were interviewed by the series executive
consultant daphne barack
hellyer has never spoken on television
before about guillen
she's the most haunted lady in the usa
in fact in the world
but she needed to get out weeks after
epstein's death this picture surfaced of
maxwell at an in and out burger in los
angeles it took minutes
for someone to recognize her
take a photo and send it to the press
and we had to make it disappear again at
one point maxwell was thought to be in
france with her brother kevin hellyer
says it was a decoy so we put
two people that look similar to galen
and kevin
in the public eye
in a well-known street in paris in
december 2019 hellyer says maxwell
bought a house on 156 acres in bradford
new hampshire
on july 2nd of 2020 federal agents
swarmed the property we thought it was a
bit of an overkill it was more like
hollywood than real life maxwell was
arrested charged with being part of
jeffrey epstein's alleged sex
trafficking conspiracy of helping him
recruit groom and ultimately abuse
underage girls the picture and the net
that is painted of my sister
is one
thousand degrees away from the person
that i know isabelle maxwell is
guillen's older sister she's innocent
and she has our love and support i'm
extremely relieved that neither of my
parents are alive to see it
because they would have been profoundly
shocked ian maxwell galen's older
brother has his own questions for his
sister's accusers can you look me in the
eye and tell me honestly
that
guillen maxwell was responsible
for your abuse or was it jeffrey epstein
really
who should be here not my sister
when you read
that guillen maxwell
says she had no involvement in this
what's your reaction to that
i think it's disgraceful and these
people are going to burn in home
epstein accuser sarah ransom says she
was 22 when she met epstein in 2006. you
know gilean was jeffrey's
right hand right hand
you know like the lieutenant of the
whole pyramid you know she made sure
that we all stayed in line
that when we were called to his bedroom
that we went i hate her more
you hate he land more way more because
because she's a woman and she fed women
to him maria farmer has accused epstein
and maxwell of assaulting her in a
separate civil suit
in 2019 she told me she witnessed gulen
recruiting young women for epstein she
went to places like central park i was
with her a couple times in the car so
she would say stop the car and she would
dash out farmer and ransom are not part
of the government's case against maxwell
since her arrest in 2020 maxwell has
found little public support then
president trump was one of the few to
offer sympathy i just wish her well
frankly i can't think of anybody
other than guilin's friends and family
who are wishing guilin well right now
that's not the narrative
so for the president of the united
states to stand up when asked a question
and to wish her well
that was
surprising and personally i was grateful
ian maxwell says his sister became the
government's target only after jeffrey
epstein died in prison they lost him
and so there has to be somebody to pay
the price there has to be the patsy
gillen is paying that price and she's
paying it every day she's now spent more
time in jail than jeffrey epstein spent
himself in jail now how can that be
correct